>> Will Sentance: Vì vậy, chúng tôi thấy ở đó rằng chúng tôi đã tăng cường
thế giới quan của chúng tôi về công cụ JavaScript của chúng tôi trông như thế nào
bằng cách thêm các hàm mặt tiền, được gọi là API trình duyệt web.
Điều đó có nghĩa là các tính năng của trình duyệt web mà chúng ta có thể sử dụng,
tương tác với, từ bên trong JavaScript bằng cách sử dụng các hàm không thực sự
bất kỳ thứ gì trong JavaScript.
Thay vào đó, chúng là mặt tiền cho các tính năng của trình duyệt web.
Khi chúng tôi làm như vậy, chúng tôi đã phân tích cú pháp thiết kế để chấp nhận một số đầu vào nhất định.
Và điều đầu tiên ở đây trong bộ hẹn giờ là chức năng
mà chúng tôi muốn sau đó phân tích cú pháp thành hàng đợi.
Và sau đó quay trở lại JavaScript khi vòng lặp sự kiện bắt đầu, vâng, bạn đã sẵn sàng,
bạn đã chạy xong tất cả mã JavaScript đồng bộ của mình, không có gì trên
ngăn xếp khóa học và bạn đã chạy xong nhật ký bảng điều khiển của mình ở đó ở dưới cùng.
Vì vậy, bây giờ, chức năng thứ ba của bạn đã được phân tích cú pháp từ JavaScript để
trình duyệt web được phép quay trở lại Y để gọi lại Q được thực thi
trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi, được rồi.
Đó là giải pháp hai, hãy xem những gì các bạn thân yêu của chúng ta
trong nhóm thiết kế kịch bản đã thêm vào mô hình này.
Họ đã thêm một trình tăng cường khả năng đọc,
được gọi là Lời hứa. >> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi đã nói rằng bộ của chúng tôi
hết thời gian, tôi đặt thời gian ra ngoài là chỉ làm việc
bên ngoài JavaScript trong trình duyệt web.
Nó không làm bất cứ điều gì quan tâm đến trình duyệt web.
Chà, lời hứa là hai mục tiêu, chúng làm được hai điều.
Một bên ngoài JavaScript, trong trình duyệt web.
Chúng quay cuồng.
Họ bắt đầu, một số tính năng trình duyệt web nền.
Họ sẽ làm được.
Cũng giống như lần đó tôi đã hẹn giờ.
Vì vậy, có một loại chức năng mặt tiền mới có, có điều đó.
Nhưng đồng thời nó thực hiện điều gì đó trong JavaScript.
Nó sẽ tạo ra một đối tượng đặc biệt được gọi là đối tượng hứa hẹn,
nó sẽ được trả lại ngay lập tức.
Đặt trả về thời gian chờ trong JavaScript.
Những thứ màu xanh ở đây là tất cả những thứ của trình duyệt web.
Nó không làm bất cứ điều gì trong JavaScript.
Những chức năng mặt tiền mới này, những chức năng như tìm nạp, những mặt tiền trình duyệt web mới này dành cho
các tính năng của trình duyệt web, chúng đang tải lên Java Script.
Giống như phần này Tìm nạp, sẽ ngay lập tức trả về một thứ gì đó vào
Java Script, một đối tượng giữ chỗ được gọi là một lời hứa,
nó sẽ có một thuộc tính gọi là giá trị, ban đầu không có gì cả.
Giá trị đó sẽ tự động được điền vào sau này khi web nền
chẳng hạn như nhiệm vụ của trình duyệt là lấy dữ liệu từ Twitter, đưa dữ liệu đó trở lại.
Khi tác vụ trình duyệt web nền đó kết thúc,
nó sẽ được lưu trữ trong đó ngay lập tức được trả lại
đối tượng trên giá trị của nó thuộc tính dữ liệu được trả lại từ máy chủ.
Bây giờ chúng ta sẽ làm hai việc với các chức năng mặt tiền này.
Một mặt, chúng tôi sẽ thiết lập nó trong trình duyệt web.
JavaScript không có khả năng nói chuyện với Internet.
Vì vậy, nó sẽ là một lệnh cho trình duyệt web
để nói chuyện từ internet và lấy một số dữ liệu.
Đồng thời, không giống như thời gian đặt ra không làm gì trong JavaScript,
thay vào đó, chúng tôi tạm dừng ở một chức năng sẽ được kích hoạt sau này.
Thay vào đó, chúng tôi sẽ trả về một đối tượng có trình giữ chỗ
được gọi là giá trị sẽ được điền vào bằng dữ liệu của chúng tôi từ công việc nền.
Và nhân tiện, nó sẽ có một tài sản được che giấu, được gọi là sự hoàn thiện,
điều đó sẽ có chức năng sẽ được kích hoạt
tự động trong JavaScript khi giá trị đó được cập nhật.
Hứa hẹn như một trình giữ chỗ cho
dữ liệu chúng tôi sẽ lấy lại từ công việc nền của trình duyệt web.
Chúng tôi cũng đính kèm chức năng,
mà chúng tôi muốn hoãn chạy cho đến khi hoàn thành công việc nền.
Chúng tôi sẽ xem lý do cho
đó là nếu tôi cố gắng chạy chức năng trên giá trị của trình giữ chỗ đó
phản đối vấn đề là ngay lập tức sẽ không có bất kỳ dữ liệu nào ở đó.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi cần đính kèm chức năng trên trình kích hoạt khi dữ liệu quay trở lại
dữ liệu đó trên cùng một đối tượng.
Chúng ta sẽ thấy điều đó trong giây lát.
Hứa đối tượng nước sẽ kích hoạt chức năng đó và nhân tiện,
giá trị trả về cho các tính năng của trình duyệt web hoạt động, ví dụ: lấy dữ liệu
từ máy chủ, sẽ là đầu vào của chức năng đính kèm, đối số của nó.
Chúng tôi sẽ đi qua tất cả những điều này một cách chính xác nhưng đó là tổng quan.